did you miss me at yeah I was gonna see
we did I was like anymore a GT say
goodbye to Heidi Klum and Mel B and
hello to a new America's Got Talent
judging panel this year there's a lot of
fun things I'm just starting it out with
a bang et has learned Julianne Hough and
Gabrielle Union will be joining Simon
Cowell and Howie Mandel on the NBC show
as judges for season 14 a source close
to a GT production tells et that the
network simply wanted to quote change
things up adding Heidi Mel B and Tyra
have major projects coming up that they
need to focus on there was no drama
some familiar faces are joining the
family for good too
it's fun it's a fashion show but it's
also the greatest talent competition in
the world man Terry Crews will
officially replace Tyra Banks as host no
you know what I actually pacifically did
not try to get any pointers that way
from from Nick or tired of both good
friends of mine but I wanted to bring
what I was going to bring you know what
I mean
[Music]
I mean he brings a different vibe is a
guy he's got this pectin going over this
crazy outfit I love my fingers great of
course it's a yes in me I love this guy
while we will miss Mel B spunk in the
judges chair we're sure she will bring
that same energy to the Spice Girls
reunion tour we want our fans to know
that this is gonna be like a celebration
and we're gonna go back in time
Heidi is also gearing up for the biggest
celebration tying the knot with fiance
Tom earlier this month she dished on her
wedding planning process so far along
you know with two Germans it will be
very organized and fun time you guys set
a date yet oh yeah I think he did and
Heidi will still be on the small screen
in her new Amazon series with Tim Gunn
yeah we're starting yeah we're starting
to film this summer I'm very excited but
I don't want to give too much away
because I also want people to have a
surprise
[Music]
[Applause]